how quickly the misery and destruction
of War has spread across Ukraine as
Russia seeks to impose its brutal will
on the country but is the conflict now
entering its most critical phase the
question to Lieutenant General Ben
Hodges former Commander United States
Army Europe and my guest this week from
Frankfurt this is going to be that's
what I mean it's going to be a decisive
week a decisive week ahead of whether or
not we can bring Force the Russians to
culminate so that they can no longer
attack the targeting of civilians and
residential areas prompted General
Hodges to call for NATO to impose a
no-fly zone across Ukraine but the
alliance said no with this weakness or
wise tactics
and one of moscow's continuing threats
to use nuclear weapons so it's almost
like we are talking ourselves out of
taking more uh uh forceful actions uh
that we should or that and much more
uncomfortable there
[Music]
Lieutenant General Ben Hodges welcome to
conflict Zone
and thank you can we start with the
recent Russian attack on the yavouri
military base close to the Polish border
with Ukraine 35 people died this came
after Russia had warned that NATO
weapons shipments to Ukraine would be
seen as legitimate targets we don't of
course know if some of those shipments
pass through that base but looking at
the proximity of the attack to a NATO
border how serious is that for the
alliance do you think
well
um I'm more concerned about the impact
on uh the facility at Java Reef this is
a training center that from the uh
Soviet times that we the U.S army and
Canada invested a lot of money over the
last six or seven years to turn it into
a meaningful training area training
center for Ukrainian forces uh and
that's what it was for over the last
several years I don't know that it has
become a logistics Hub or anything that
I think the Pentagon has been pretty
closed mouth about this uh but I mean
going after going after that base also
is a demonstration that the Russians
still have the capability to reach that
far and I imagine they also intended
this as a warning
and a warning or an actual attempt to
pull NATO directly into the war do you
think that do you think that's what they
want to do I do not think that they want
to get NATO into the war that's in fact
that's the last thing that they want is
a situation where you've got all 30
Nations plus against Russia I think this
is more about them trying to interdict
um the logistical lines of communication
do you think NATO will continue to
Supply Military assistance to Ukraine
and will it defend those shipments if
necessary directly
for sure we're going to continue and in
fact we've got to accelerate we need to
be doing something on the scale of the
of the Berlin airlift with the with a
sense of urgency uh the next 10 days are
decisive in my view uh the next 10 days
uh if we uh accelerate and expand the
delivery of support
I think the Russians actually are close
to culminating to reaching the point
where they can no longer continue the
attack if we keep the pressure on them
for the next 10 days
there's a lot of focus on China right
now the U.S is claiming Russia has asked
Beijing for military help potentially a
huge development there isn't it
now this is important uh the Chinese
have to decide what they want their role
in the world to be
the Russians obviously are in trouble
they know it not only are they
recruiting syrians to come join the
fight because their own Manpower
shortage is uh growing increasingly
severe
and they need financial help which is
why they're turning to China and I think
they're looking for some material
support as well so China really has a an
opportunity
um and an important decision to make but
the possibility of an open military
alliance between the world's largest
country geographically and the world's
most populous nation do you think NATO
is even considered such an alarming
development
oh there's no doubt the alliance has
been thinking about this this featured
prominently over the past year and a lot
of the Strategic thinking and the
conversations does it scare you
no because I I just don't think it's I
don't think it's going to happen
actually I there's not much Advantage
for China in being handcuffed to uh a
Russia that is going to be destitute uh
and without a friend in the world other
than energy for its own economy and uh
easier access to the Arctic I don't see
too many advantages for China here this
is bad for business for them General
Hodges on the ground in Ukraine the
battle for Kiev seems to be gathering
momentum is this going to decide the
outcome of this war
I think that the Russians are not going
to be able to encircle Keith let alone
capture it I mean look uh for almost 19
days now they've been trying to capture
mariopal that should have been the
easiest City for them to capture given
the proximity of their Navy in the sea
of azov uh forces there in Crimea and in
donbass and yet they still have not been
able to capture marijuope I don't
believe that they're gonna that they
have the ability to actually encircle
Keith I was there five weeks ago uh I've
been there several times this is a very
very large city on the banks of one of
the largest rivers in Europe very
complex Urban Terrain they don't have
the manpower to encircle it but the
failure if Russia failed to take Kiev
that would be a catastrophic blow to
them wouldn't it wouldn't they have
orders when they have orders to keep on
regardless flatten the city if necessary
take it
there's no doubt that they will continue
to launch rockets and missiles into Keys
the way they've done other Ukrainian
cities which is why it's so important
that the aid that we are providing to
Ukraine include the capability to
destroy the rocket launchers and missile
uh launching systems that Russians are
using but this is this is going to be
that's why I mean it's going to be a
decisive week a decisive week ahead on
whether or not we can bring Force the
Russians to culminate so that they can
no longer attack and then Ukraine has a
more advantageous position for whatever
sort of negotiations are happening you
clearly want NATO to do more to help
Ukraine than it's been doing last week
you co-signed an open letter calling for
the alliance to impose a no-fly zone
over Ukraine to avert and deter Russian
bombardment you said more must be done
to prevent more wide-scale casualties
and a potential bloodbath do you feel
NATO has been too soft
I think that there we are overreacting
to Russian threats about expansion of
the war about nuclear weapons I don't
believe that the Kremlin will use a
nuclear weapon uh I don't you know first
of all Putin cannot do it by himself and
I don't believe that the people around
him are actually interested in just
becoming a nuclear threat so it's almost
like we are talking ourselves out of
taking more uh
uh forceful actions uh that we should uh
we're we are talking too much about what
we can't do and what we won't do and not
enough about what we what we can do look
schreiba needs a July 1995 European
troops under United Nations mandate
stood outside the city while Republic of
surgical forces uh murdered 8 000
Bosnian men and boys I do not want us to
be a part of something like that again
your letter said NATO leaders should
make clear that they won't countenance
Russian attacks on civilian areas but
they have countenance them and they
continue to do so and they turn down
your proposal for the no-fly zone
um
does that concern you
um
that really that they're seeding the
advantage to the Russians here yeah and
obviously I'm not a very compelling
writer
um yeah I do feel like that we are we
have lost some momentum the first two
weeks of this uh I thought the White
House was doing a terrific job the the
Allies sticking together and we're still
sticking together but the last four days
it feels like we begin to become more
risk-averse more cautious and and the
messaging was more about no escalation
and less about
stopping the murder of thousands of
Ukrainian Innocent ukrainians but
there's a liquid dilemma here for NATO
isn't there isn't it NATO has to do
what's right for NATO
um it can't necessarily do what's right
for Ukraine at the same time the two
aren't necessarily the same are they
um I don't know that I accept the
premise of the question you're right
Ukraine is not a NATO member and the
alliance exists for the collective
defense of all of its members
but
if you
will accept the notion that what's
happening in Ukraine is not limited to
Ukraine and I don't mean a stray missile
going over the Border I'm talking about
what Putin is doing what is the impact
on Europe stability and Security in
Europe then I think NATO has to take a
broader view of this Joe Biden has
repeatedly felt the need to State
publicly that the U.S won't directly
intervene against Russian forces in
Ukraine he did so again last Friday is
is Biden pushing back against domestic
pressure for him to do more and if so
would you suspect that pressure is
coming partly from inside the Pentagon
um actually the Pentagon is usually the
most conservative institution in
Washington so I don't think he's getting
too much pressure from the Pentagon to
do more obviously the joint staff and
the Department of Defense uh uh are
doing what they should do prudent
planning anticipation of requirements
and and giving the president options but
I don't think he's getting pressure from
the Pentagon uh the Congress seems to be
in a bipartisan way in favor of doing a
lot more
um I I think that the president has
overstated this business about no we're
not going to do this because it's as if
it's automatically going to be World War
III I don't know that I agree with that
he Biden has delivered a strong warning
about chemical weapons saying Russia
would pay a severe price if it used them
that's a that's an easy threat to make
how seriously do you take it coming from
Biden I mean Biden was vice president
when Barack Obama gave a similar Redline
warning to Syria which did use chemical
weapons but the warning never turned
into action could it be the same this
time round
um I would think not no you're right
that uh President Biden was vice
president during the Obama
Administration when this famous uh red
line was given to the Assad regime
um the Assad regime jumped right over it
with Russian help in the U.S the UK
France Germany did nothing and I think
that emboldened the Russians to go ahead
and be even more aggressive so that's
why President Biden has not said this is
a red line because that that figure of
speech uh you box yourself in I would
anticipate though that there would be
consequences uh that would be even more
severe for the Kremlin although we're
running out of things other things to do
to them
short of kinetic Force but chemical
weapons is part of their Warfare
Doctrine isn't it I mean they've used it
specifically against their opposition uh
figures like Alexa navalny and some of
those that they've attacked on foreign
streets in Europe
um a former U.S official at the National
Security Council says Moscow accepts the
use of chemical agents in Warfare the
stakes for Putin are existential he said
if that's one more tool he can throw at
this thing he will do you think that's
possible
yeah I agree with Fiona Hill's comments
a few weeks ago when she was asked about
this and she said oh yes he would that
doesn't mean he will but certainly I
think uh he would uh countenance
countenance this uh even if it was not
for State survival but if it was
necessary to accelerate the uh
extermination of ukrainians or to
depopulate the area by getting
ukrainians on the road the most likely
scenario with chemical weapons is
probably something like some Syria
chlorine not the more uh uh not
something like a nerve agent chlorine
still kills people but the casualty rate
probably is somewhere uh similar to
Rockets artillery
um but it puts things in a different
category and certainly you know the the
idea of seeing kids and old people uh
murdered by any kind of chemical weapon
any kind of gas is going to put immense
pressure on the administration and other
heads of state and government to take
action and it should
and those who will be most worried about
the threat of chemical weapons would be
Eastern Europe Baltic states
they've been warning about Russian
aggression in the region for some time
question is why nobody's been listening
to their voices over the years well I
think that um there is a large part of
Western Europe that is further away uh
from Russia but also inside the United
States uh and inside the UK where you've
got huge Russian money
business energy dependencies so there's
been a reluctance to uh confront this
for a variety of bad reasons and I would
say shame on everybody that said come on
Russia's not going to do this I live in
Frankfurt I hear it from uh friends all
the time before this happened come on
what are you worried about it makes no
sense Putin would never attack and here
we are and unfortunately in the real
world you can't make your threats go
away by not by looking the other way or
wishing that they didn't exist and and
so we're paying the price for that now
to date NATO's reinforcements in those
countries don't have too much deterrent
value do they a few thousand extra
troops a few more fighter aircraft not
nearly enough is it well first of all I
would completely disagree with you Tim
that they don't have
um much deterrent effect that it's been
pretty effective so far but I do agree
with you that we don't have enough we
don't have enough air and missile
defense we don't have enough Logistics
the ability to move quickly across
Europe is not what it needs to be to
really be a strong deterrent should
Russian forces move into Belarus in
stronger numbers which I expect is going
to happen thanks to this bogus uh
constitutional referendum in Belarus a
few weeks ago then this raises the risk
for our allies in Estonia Latvia and
Lithuania so we do need to improve air
and missile defense we do need to
improve the logistical preparations
um but uh I would also say I think that
the alliance is now going to consider
more favorably permanent basing in
Romania and Poland and Baltic countries
not just rotational forces I would
support that
and what do you think the reaction from
Russia would be uh of course they will
they will complain about it but in my
view they're in no position to complain
they've
um we did not have permanent basing in
there since the nato-russia founding act
because one of the provisions said no
permanent basing and so we adhered to
that but when the Russians uh abrogated
the NATO Russia founding act with their
attack in Georgia and then of Ukraine
the alliance continued to live by that
it's obvious that our good faith effort
uh has not been rewarded by good
behavior by the Russians and so we need
to replace that naivety with some
serious uh deterrence measures
you talked earlier about uh wanting to
stop Russia calling the shots and it's
about time that the NATO alliance called
the shots
um how do should the West be setting the
agenda instead of responding to moscow's
well first of all they need to be
feeling pain immediately and in a lot of
different places the sanctions are
important uh the effects are going to be
felt for years to come
but as you know sanctions take a while
to really start delivering effect some
inconveniences for Russians now but the
real pain is going to be felt in the
coming months to include Russia probably
will default on 150 billion dollar debt
on loans because their economy is in
tatters and and aeroflot will not be
able to fly anymore because they don't
have repair parts and so there's going
to be serious impact in the coming
months but in more immediately we need
to be doing two things in addition
obviously to providing Aid to the
ukrainians that they need number one we
should be trying to reach every Russian
family and tell them what's going on
there's a reason that the Kremlin has
put a media blackout all over Russia
that social media does not allow people
to understand what's happening the older
demographic in Russia of course is
completely bought into state-run TV but
there is another part of the population
I don't think so there are still
thousands of Russians that have courage
to go out and protest the woman that we
all saw on Russian TV last night that
jumped in behind the commentator with
the sign saying stop the war this is
there on one April on the first of April
130
000 Russian families are required to
send their son to be conscripts for the
Russian army if we could reach just 10
or 20 percent of that hundred and thirty
thousand and tell them to resist to not
send their son I think that would send a
shock wave across Russia and that could
really generate more uh domestic
pressure that's hard to do but I think
this this is doable
General Hodges you've been pretty
scathing about Europe's defense posture
in the past in your book future War you
say that Europe is finally waking up
from a 30-year strategic Slumber but
there's little Unity of effort or
purpose and even less strategic
Direction any sign that's changing in
the last few days the idea that the EU
would actually ship weapons to Ukraine
or anywhere else certainly speaks to a
sudden Awakening doesn't it yeah I would
say it's been quite an Awakening uh in
Germany has been the key here when
Chancellor Schultz made his speech about
three weeks ago there in front of the
bundestag where he talked about two
percent we talked about the 100 billion
Euro and allowing weapons to to move
through Germany or weapons that over
which Germany had some control this was
critical that to me was the door
slamming shut on any hope that Putin
might have had to separate the alliance
or to divide the U.S from Europe German
leadership here is essential now German
it's not just the economy it's sort of
the moral Authority that Germany has
accrued over the last seven or eight
decades and I think that German uh
political leadership the so-called
Elites realized that they were in danger
of seeing that credibility erode
right underneath their feet
they could not claim to be the champion
of uh European values and of the uh
gazumpta oropasia or um
frieden's ordinal the the peace and
stability culture of Europe right if
they still die while Russia smashed it
what what's alarming in your judgment is
the fact that while Russia is exploiting
the evolution in military technology
Hypersonic weapons laser particle beam
systems Europe you say has chosen not to
how serious is it that Europe should
actually try to catch up with these
Advanced Technologies well of course if
you want to defeat those Technologies or
deter their use against you you have to
demonstrate that you have the ability to
do that now Stand Fast the fact that the
Russians have not been able to actually
employ very effectively much of these
Technologies I've been a little bit
surprised that I have not seen more
cyber use that I have not seen more
effective integration of their modern
systems did you overestimate their
capabilities I did I absolutely did
um and I think as I look back
the missing ingredient it's not it's not
the device it's not the platform it's
the training and the culture of
Readiness and I think what we're seeing
is a result of Decades of corruption and
uh false reporting inside the Russian
defense industry and inside the ministry
of Defense a lot of money was spent but
they didn't get what they paid for
you said recently that Kremlin is always
in a war state of mind but but NATO
isn't is it and it hasn't been
um can you now foresee NATO moving
excuse me to the same kind of War
footing as Russia does it need to I
think we're going to see uh more people
um
being more clear-eyed about the threat I
mean you know we we probably uh first of
all couldn't believe that there would be
a big war in Europe
secondly we were accustomed to what war
looked like in Afghanistan and uh Iraq
uh not with missiles flying into
buildings and thousands of being people
being killed and displaced uh like we're
seeing right now so that we had
forgotten about The lethality of
high-end uh of War so I think there's a
gram realization that we if we want to
prevent that you have to be you have to
be ready for it
what comes next in your view as far as
the battles are concerned in Ukraine
um if Putin won't accept to lose and
can't be seen to lose in the
international Arena what do you think
he'd he would do is the West on a knife
edge here
I don't think so
um I think we've we have taken too much
counsel of our own fears about a nuclear
conflict and allowed him to use threats
to keep us from doing what needs to be
done I'm not saying that there's no risk
and obviously nobody I know wants it to
go that way but I think we have given
him too much credit for the for the
ability to do those things and we've
deterred ourselves what comes next if
I'm right that within the next 10 10 to
12 Days Uh Russian forces culminate they
can no longer continue the attack
they will obviously want to hang on to
what they've got uh this is when we
should be pouring it on we'll have a
better negotiating position and we
should demand that they go back to not
just pre-february 24 but but President
Biden said that Ukrainian sovereignty
is a priority for the United States that
they should leave Crimea they should
leave the dumbass and then we get on
with recovery I mean there's going to be
more than three million refugees that
want to come home this is going to be a
massive problem to rebuild and help
repatriate people but also as you and
your viewers know there are millions of
people across Europe and the Middle East
that depend on grain from Ukraine for
food we're going to have a serious food
problem here over the next year until
Ukraine is able to start exporting
agriculture again and the humanitarian
emergency that's now a very real a very
present reality for people uh in the
major cities people are living in in
what one Aid agency called apocalyptic
conditions we just stand by and watch
that for the time being no of course not
there are dozens and dozens of agencies
that are out already trying to help uh
particularly in Poland where agencies
have moved there to help deal with
refugees uh and some are working inside
Ukraine I know several people who are
personally involved in this
um but there's also going to be a part
of the cleanup as you know from all your
years as a journalists uh in a conflict
like this there is so much what we call
uxo unexploded ordinance everywhere the
cluster Munitions that the Russians have
used uh rounds that did not detonate
this stuff is lying all over the
battlefield everywhere and so as people
go back in and try to clean up these
cities
this is this is going to be a real
problem for quite some time and also
these nuclear plants I mean we've got
some cleanup to do there as well all
right General hudges it's been good to
have you on conflict Zone thanks very
much indeed for your time thank you
thanks for the privilege team
[Music]